este reporte corresponde a 2022 cuando
todavía estábamos saliendo de la
pandemia Pero qué otros factores han
contribuido a esta situación
y como bien dijiste Andrés la situación
de seguridad alimentaria a nivel global
no ha hecho más que empeorar nos lo dice
nuestro secretario general de las
Naciones Unidas Gutiérrez que dice que
estamos avanzando en dirección
equivocada que realmente hoy este año
los datos del 2022 nos dicen que tenemos
65 millones más de personas que sufren
hambre en el mundo más que el año
anterior en el 2021 entonces realmente
un grave problema a nivel mundial y a
qué se debe mucho a los conflictos
ustedes estaban ahora hablando de
conflictos los conflictos son uno de los
grandes determinantes para que la gente
pase hambre y no considate consiga tener
una dieta adecuada y luego también claro
la crisis climática los efectos de los
desastres naturales que conocemos
también en la región así como la
inflación alimentaria que ha sido
provocada por las diferentes crisis no
la crisis en cascada la crisis de
Ucrania la última de ellas no Entonces
con todo esto lamentablemente no vamos
bien para cumplir los objetivos de
desarrollo sostenible número dos en
concreto es decir que no se está
haciendo lo suficiente para mitigar esta
situación Mira realmente se está
haciendo bastante nosotros como programa
mundial de alimentos trabajamos con los
gobiernos en todo el mundo incluyendo en
latinoamérica del Caribe para buscar
alternativas y oportunidades que
consigamos realmente reducir la pobreza
la desigualdad que las personas puedan
tener una dieta mínima pero por ejemplo
en latinoamérica del Caribe tenemos en
este momento la dieta básica o sea es
decir si tú te quieres comprar una
comida normal durante un día para tu
familia es la dieta más cara del mundo
es cuatro punto dos dólares por persona
por día y es carísimo poder acceder a
unos platos adecuados cuando hay una
crisis no hay bastante empleo los
empleos están relativamente pagados de
una manera bastante baja Entonces
tenemos que trabajar conjuntamente para
apoyar reducir esas desigualdades y la
pobreza y que la gente pueda acceder
a esta alimentación los gobiernos están
haciendo mucho trabajo a través de
sistemas de protección social en los que
los apoyamos también programa de
alimentación escolar que son muy muy
obvios pero también en nuestra región
tenemos algunas zonas en conflictos que
son muy preocupantes como Haití
precisamente a propósito de esta mención
que usted hace de América Latina siempre
que se habla de esta de esta región y
los problemas de seguridad alimentaria
se menciona a países como Venezuela y
Haití Pero hay otros países que también
se encuentran en esta lista de crisis
Por decirlo así bueno en latinoamérica
del Caribe en este informe se reporta
que hay 17 millones de personas que no
pueden tener una alimentación normal
cada día y que están en riesgo de caer
en problemas de nutrición o incluso de
hambre como hemos visto el año pasado lo
vimos en Haití y se debía que sería
realmente un conflicto a la violencia a
la a la imposibilidad de las personas de
de llegar incluso a poder comprar o a
trabajar para comprar o a tener algún
apoyo externo en ese sentido Por ejemplo
te cuento estuve en Haití recientemente
y estaba hablando con mujeres que viven
en ley que es uno de los barrios más
calientes más complicados de de Puerto
Pranks y me decían que no conseguían el
alimento para sus hijos y quedaban
Muchas gracias al programa mundial de
alimentos a unicef a la OMS a todos los
que habían llegado y les habían dado la
alimentación para mantener a sus hijos
con una dieta normal y así conseguimos
en Puerto plan sacar a diecinueve mil
personas que estaban en fase casi de
hambre y hambruna a una fase un poco
menos todavía de crisis pero un poco
menos peor digamos entonces estamos
claros que que la violencia el conflicto
conjuntamente con los cambios climáticos
como dijimos y también el costo de la
dieta son uno de los factores más
importantes tenemos muchas oportunidades
en latinoamérica del Caribe para
evidentemente evitar esto y tenemos que
trabajar juntas y juntos con gobiernos y
con todos para evitar que haya personas
que se van a la cama con hambre señora
Castro combatir la seguridad alimentaria
es una tarea que se le ha dejado a los
gobiernos pero nosotros como ciudadanos
que podemos hacer para reducir este
problema muy brevemente por favor
sí los ciudadanos pueden hacer muchísimo
el primero es reducir el el gasto el
despilfarro diría yo servirnos Esos
grandes platos tirar comida etcétera
cuando realmente no es necesario tirar
comida debemos ajustar ajustarnos a lo
que debemos comer para guardar para
nosotros luego también podemos
contribuir el sector privado etcétera
pueden contribuir para que los sistemas
los gobiernos y las organizaciones de
Naciones Unidas tengamos fondos
adecuados para atender a los más
vulnerables a través de transferencias
sociales o transferencias de alimentos
esos son por ejemplo rápidamente dos
soluciones muy rápidas que te doy